the simplest bound that a random
variable differs by much from its
expectation is due to a guy named mark
of a Russian probability theorist
and this is Markov spam that we're going
to talk about let's illustrate it with a
memorable example of IQ in the MIT
context we may it may be a radical idea
but IQ was this thing that was invented
for intelligence quotient in the late
19th century I believe might have been
early 20th
it was meant as a an effort to break the
mold at Harvard of hiring the children
of wealthy alumni and the idea was to
have merit-based admissions and there
was going to be some objective measure
that did not depend on social class of
the ability that people had in Harvard
was going to admit students based on
merit and their intelligence quotient so
the original design of the intelligent
quotient by a bunch of psychologists was
that the average was supposed to be a
hundred over the whole population which
of course is around here there just
aren't very many people with an IQ of
just a hundred anyway let's ask this
extreme question yes there's around the
elite universities are a lot of people
with IQ is much higher than hunter than
100 but what fraction of the population
could possibly have an IQ as high as 300
and I'm not sure that an IQ of as high
as 300 has ever been recorded but we're
talking logically here is it possible
for a lot of people to have an IQ of
greater equals 100 and the answer is no
you can't possibly have more than a
third of the population have an IQ of
300 because if more than 1/3 had an IQ
of 300 then that third alone would
contribute one third of 300 to the
average which would be greater than 100
so you can't have more than a third of
the population have an IQ of triple the
expected value of the IQ so that's the
basic bound
so we can restate it this way the the
probability that a randomly chosen
person has an IQ greater equal to 100 we
can say is absolutely less than or equal
to the expected value of IQ namely 100
divided by 300 and just parameterizing
it if we ask what's the probability that
the IQ is greater equal to some amount X
it's less than or equal to 100 over X by
exactly that reasoning and this is
basically Marcos bound except there's
one implicit fact that we're using and
deriving the previous identity or
inequality that IQ is bounded by 100 our
logic was that you can't have more than
population X with an IQ of more than a
hundred X because that would contribute
X times a hundred over X or more than a
hundred to the average and the average
is only a hundred that's only a problem
if there are a if there are no negative
terms negative IQs to offset the excess
contribution of the fraction of the
population that has this high IQ but
we're implicitly using the fact that IQ
is never negative iq runs from 0 up to
unlimited amount but it's never negative
and that means that that contribution
from the 1/3 of the population that has
an IQ of over 300 can't be offset by
negative values it's there and it messes
up the average it forces the average up
so we were using the fact that IQ is
always non-negative and by this very
same reasoning I'm not going to belabor
you with a more formal proof there's a
trivial one in the text it's easy the
theorems markups bound says that if R is
non-negative then the probability that R
is greater than or equal to X is less
than or equal to the expectation of R
divided by X and this holds for any X
greater than 0 of course it's silly to
state if this bound is is greater than
equal to 1 it's not an interesting
bounces probability is never greater
equal to 1 so we might as well just
restrict ourselves to X's that are
greater than the expectation of R
because those are the only X's that are
going to give us a non-trivial bound
that's less than 1 again if R is
non-negative and the probability that
our exceeds an amount X is less than or
equal to the expectation of R over X and
that's the Markov bound if you restate
it in terms of deviation from the mean
you could formulate it this way the
probability that R is greater equal to a
constant times its mean mu is an
abbreviation for the expectation of R is
less than or equal to one over C so in
that we can understand that as a bound
on the deviation from the mean above the
mean in this case that R as the as the
factor of the expectation increases the
probability decreases proportionally so
the probability that R is greater equal
to three times the expected amount is
less than or equal to 1/3 which was what
we saw with the IQ example so look this
Markov bound in general is very weak as
I said I don't think has ever been an IQ
recorded that was as high as 300 and in
almost all the examples that you come
across your there'll be other
information that allows you to deduce
higher bounds on the probability that a
random variable is significantly bigger
than its expectation but if you don't
have any information about the random
variable other than that it's not
negative that as a matter of fact Markov
bound is tight
you can't possibly reach a stronger
contribution because there are
non-negative random variables where the
probability that they are greater than
or equal to a given amount X is is in
fact equal to their expectation divided
by X so the Markov bound is weak in
application but it's the strongest
condition you can make on the very
limited hypotheses that it makes about
properties of the random variable and
it's also pretty obvious I hope from
this examples that we've talked about
but the amazing thing is how useful it
is we will get mileage out of it by
using it in clever ways so let's talk
about the first clever way and suppose
that we're thinking about IQ is greater
equal to 100 but I bring into into the
story another fact that we haven't
mentioned
for which is let's suppose that as a
matter of fact IQs of less than 50 just
don't occur I think they might actually
but but there's a certain point where
you just are not functioning at all and
it's not clear that it makes sense to
ever talk about somebody who's in a coma
as having an IQ maybe they have an IQ of
zero but let's assume that pragmatically
IQ is never less than or equal to 15
okay now if I'm if I tell you that I
know that IQ is greater or equal to 50
then I can actually get a better bound
out of mark Huff because now knowing
that IQ is greater than equal to 50 or
IQ minus 50 is becomes a non-negative
random variable which I couldn't be sure
it was before because IQ might have gone
below 50 now that I know that it's
always above 50 IQ minus 50 is
non-negative and markoff's bound will
apply to IQ minus 50 and applying it to
IQ minus 50 will give you a better bound
because now looking at the probability
that the IQ is greater equal to a
hundred of course that's the same as
saying that IQ minus 50 is Gregg legal
to three hundred minus 50 um which
50 the average expected value of IQ
minus 50 is a hundred minus 50 so we're
asking whether this non-negative random
variable is greater than or equal to 250
and the answer is that's less than or
equal to its expectation over 250 which
is one-fifth 50 over 250 and that's a
tighter bound than the one third we had
previously this is a general phenomenon
that you get in that helps you get
slightly stronger bands out of Markov
spam namely um if you have a non
negative variable you get a better bound
on it by shifting it so that its mean is
zero as a matter of fact even if it's
goes negative if you shift it up you can
for if you can force it to be come above
zero as a minimum then you can apply
Marko's bound to it